[Music]  well you may remember that Kendall is  actually once rumored to be dating one  direction star Harry Styles right well  now Harry's off on his own solo career  and he shooting this crazy new music  video and I do mean crazy that star  right now wow talk about a wild stunts  that is the 23 year old dangling from a  helicopter and singing just one safety  corville as he soars over the Scottish  seat taking a break from one direction  the flying stunt is for his first single  sign of the times his trademark long  wavy locks are growing back he chopped  him off for the upcoming World War two  movie Dunkirk a giant crane also lifted  Harry as he belted the song which drops  Friday he's coming out with a solo album  and it also appears he's flying solo and  not dating anyone publicly but ladies  listen up here's what he's looking for  someone is nice with a good sense of  humor  [Music]  you